he was the hawk with a beady eye for
conflict and the loyal soldier to a
president who didn't want war that split
was on show and I interviewed John
Bolton the day he got the job the surest
way to avoid conflict is to have a
strong military capability as the
ancient Romans used to say sea wees
pocheon para bellum if you want peace
prepare for war at a packed briefing
room Secretary of State Mike Pompeo who
has reportedly disagreed with Bolton
over talks with the Taliban looked
almost gleeful the president's entitled
to the staff that he wants at any moment
this is a staff person who works
directly for the president United States
and he should have people he trusts in
values and whose efforts and judgments
benefit him in delivering American
foreign policy in this White House few
get to craft their exits ambassador
Bolton was no exception in a tweet his
former boss declared I informed John
Bolton last night that his services are
no longer needed at the White House I
disagreed strongly with many of his
suggestions as did others in the
administration and therefore I asked
John for his resignation which was given
to me this morning I thank John very
much for his service I'll be naming a
new national security adviser next week
soon after mr. Bolton insisted he had
walked pursuing diplomacy with the likes
of North Korea and Iran was never going
to sit easily with John Bolton he did
have the ear of Donald Trump for some
time but the president is a man who
likes a lot of praise and agreement and
it seems Bolton simply couldn't provide
enough of either at times the old couple
looked like they could keep it cordial
yes very good John is a he has strong
views on things but that's okay
I actually temper John which is pretty
amazing isn't it on breakfast they found
common ground during the UK state visit
he was the president's frontman but
there was splits you know on Iran the
president's policy is not regime change
it never has been I've said many many
things over the years before I took this
job
on a wide variety of subjects I've
hardly hidden my views under a bushel
basket but in this job I'm the national
security adviser I'm not the national
security decision-maker and obviously
the president dictates the policy Bolton
is an ideas man
there was only space for one
decision-maker
Cordelia Lynch Sky News Washington